[Musique]
fourournier bonjour merci de nous
recevoir chez vous à la maison de la
poésie à Guyo alors c'est amusant parce
que comme ça dans l'idée générale la
poésie on voit ça des petits oiseaux des
trucs champ tout ça et là on est à côté
d'un parking enfin on est en plein en
pleine cité quoi en pleine VI bah voilà
c'est remettre les poètes dans la cité
contrairement à ce que disait Platon qui
voulait les à la porte nous grâce
à grâce à une volonté politique on a
remis la poésie au cœur de la cité quand
cette maison a été créée il y a bientôt
11 ans par par Roland N et vous vous en
êtes le le directeur depuis sa création
depuis sa création c'était une coquille
vide quand je suis arrivé et puis depuis
ben voilà on a rempli on a mis plein de
choses dedans et puis on a encore plein
de choses à mettre et et quand on voit
arriver comme ça la Maison de la Poésie
les poètes euh euh je veux dire la la
population comme ça elle vous elle vous
regarde comment euh
bahrapard ça ça surprend un peu parce
que c'est marqué maison donc les gens se
disent c'est pour nous on a confusion
avec la maison de quartier qui est juste
à côté ou mais quand il voit poésie il y
a il y a des freins qui se voilà qui se
qui se dressent et puis voilà on leur
explique on leur donne des programmes
quand ils sont dans la rue tout à
l'heure j'ai encore donné un programme à
une dame qui a regardait laaffiche je
dis partez avec profitez-en c'est
l'occasion et voilà on on fait en sorte
nous de de que les gens se rendent
compte que la poésie est faite pour tous
pour tous c'est ça oui pour tous elle
est peut-être pas faite par tous
sûrement pas mais elle est faite pour
tous ça c'est autre chose on parlera ça
c'est encore un autre domaine et et oui
c'est ça mais enfin bon il comme ça au
début ça peut faire en effet un peu peur
quand on dit poésie voilà ça ça paraît
savant quoi oui ça paraît savant mais ça
l''est pas du tout et c'est ce qu'on
cherche aussi à prouver ici c'est que
vraiment les écrivains les poète
d'aujourd'hui s'adressent à tout le
monde et et ne sont pas du tout
hermétiques il y a des difficultés c'est
pas une langue facile euh il faut il
faut faire un effort et on est on invite
les gens à faire cet effort dans le
texte mais aussi à être curieux et et
c'est tout notre travail ici c'est de de
restimuler cette curiosité qui est un
petit peu anilée par le tout venant par
la pensée unique et cetera donc on
essaie nous de de faire en sorte que les
gens se disent ah oui tiens ça c'est
pour moi voilà et alors qu'est-ce qu' on
va y entrer hein tout à l'heure mais je
vous inviter'estce qu'est-ce qu'il y a
dans cette maison de la poésie alors
dans cette maison il y a des bureaux
puisqu'on a une équipe de quatre
personnes permanentes ici depuis depuis
quasiment l'origine et une salle de
spectacle la plus petite scène salle de
spectacle de de de sa-quentin de la
communauté oui de la communauté
puisqu'on dépend la communauté
d'agglomération c'est 75 places c'est
100 m Carr au sol tout compris scène
comprise avec un avantage c'est que
cette scène elle peut se mettre où on
veut donc mes techniciens s'amusent
comme des fous avec ça les artistes
aussi les poètes aussi donc voilà c'est
modulable et on a aussi donc une
bibliothèque constitué d'à peu près oh
il doit y avoir à peu près 7 6 à 7000
titres dans la bibliothèque euh donc des
artistes des des poètes des enseignants
viennent la consulter puisqu'elle peut
pas être en prè libre elle n pas du tout
cataloguée mais voilà mais elleordonné
c'est pas une bibliothèque publique de
de de de d'auteur contemporain d'Ur
plassique de tout de tout puisque cette
maison s'occupe à la fois du patrimoine
et c'est c'est très important de savoir
sur quoi on s'appuie on a présenté ici
des spectacles sur François Villon du
Bellet Verline Molière pas mol
excusez-moi rimbau euh et cetera mais
aussi les poètes d'aujourd'hui ceux qui
font l'écriture d'aujourd'hui dans le
21e siècle voilà et ça c'est très
important qui un peu de mal aussi à se
faire connaître mal à connaître on en
parlera un petit peu tout à l'heure mais
on va on va entrer je vous invite à
entrer dans la
maison je vous précède après vous
oui voilà donc vous êtes là dans le dans
le hall dans qui est devenu salle
d'exposition aussi depuis depuis le
début c'est une volonté chez moi c'est
de faire ce lieu un lieu d'exposition
avec des expositions toujours en lien
avec avec l'écriture donc là cette ce
mois-ci on a une exposition qui marque
les 10 ans d'art c'est dire les 10 ans
d'acquisition d'œvre par la Communauté
d'Agglomération à notre demande don ces
deux œuvres voilà voilà vous avez voulu
ces deuxes j'ai tenu absolument à
rendreommage à Ladislas Kino qui vient
de décéder lundi dernier qui nous a
voilà qui qui a réalisé ces deux œuvres
de stelles importantes une stelle à
Pablo neroua et la Stelle à Martin
Luther King et elles sont en permanence
dans cette maison elles sont accrochées
sur nos murs même quand on a d'autres
expositions elles sont là elles nous
accompagnent et Kino a été un un
compagnon de route pendant quelques
années avec cette maison il était
fatigué ces dernières années mais il
nous a très longuement accompagné il
nous a soutenu c'était un un militant de
la poésie et aussi un homme très engagé
ce travail sur Martin Luther King sur
nerouda la relation qu'il avait avec
Angela Davis avec jeanjeunet avec les
Black Panthers euh voilà le son combat
contre la guerre du Vietnam contre la
guerre d'Algérie ça a été vraiment
quelque chose de très marquant le
racisme il a fait des des œuvres
magnifiques il a une très très belle
rétrospective à Lille en 2000 à
l'invitation de Martine aub et ça été
vraiment pour moi une grande découverte
à ce moment-là et je l'ai découvert ici
puisqu'il habitait à Saint-Germain en
lait où il est décédé et j'ai eu
l'occasion de de de d'aller dans son
dans sa maison une magnifique maison
musée avec des œuvres d'artistes tels
que talcouette tels que Miro Picasso qui
ont été ses proches aussi il y a une
inspiration d'ailleurs hein ah il y a il
y a des choses très fortes avec un
quelque chose de très fort chez chez
chez Kino d'abord la présence de ces
grosses boules noires ce sont les ce
sont les les les galets de les galets de
de charbon que son père allait chercher
au fond de la mine à neul les mine quand
il est arrivé en France en 1925 il est
de quelle origine il est polonais il est
né en 21 en Pologne il est arrivé en
France à l'âge de 4 ans son père était
violoniste très grand violoniste et
quand il est arrivé le seul Bouloc qu'il
a trouvé c'est dans les mines donc ça
l'a complètement marqué ça c'est une
chose et la deuxième chose c'est le
travail il y a eu trois choses la
deuxième chose c'est le travail au à la
vaporisation très très longtemps avant
les les graffeurs de rue il a travaillé
la vaporisation de la peinture euh voilà
comme le font les graffeurs maintenant
et le papier fr on pourrait retrouver he
des choses qu'on voit sur des grafes oui
oui oui complètement c'est un travail
qu'on pourrait retrouver dans la rue
hein lui il a le contrecollé ensuite il
y avait le papier froissé il avait une
formule il disait on est froissé on
meurt froissé et tous ces papiers sont
des papiers froissés contrecollés sur la
toile alors sur ces deux œuvres là mais
il a fait autre chose aussi il a
travaillé sur les grandes figures de
Bouddha il a fait des des il a réalisé
récemment une œuvre magnifique sur
l'Apocalypse qui a été montré à la
galerie d'Orval à Lille il a fait un
travail remarquable sur un chemin de
croix sur un texte de Bernard Noël qui a
été récemment montré à Paris voilà c'est
un homme qui qui qui touchait à ces
domaines là il avait une passion
incroyable pour les poètes et pour la
poésie est-ce que on va s'assoir
peut-être mais
euh quand on voit comme ça des des
œuvres on est dans une maison de la la
poésie la poésie c'est que c'est que de
l'écrit ou ça peut être alors ça peut ça
peut être de la peinture ça peut être de
la musique ça peut être un autre art moi
je je suis très sceptique je pense que
la poésie c'est d'abord je reviens moi à
l'origine poine c'est la création c'est
faire fabriquer créer tout ce qui est
création est un acte poétique mais
est-ce que ça en fait de la poésie pour
autant c'est pas
sûr après les artistes ont leur démarche
ils ont leur passion ils ont leur
relations tous les artistes qui sont
exposés ici il y en a une vingtaine nous
accompagn depuis une dizaine d'années
ont tous d'une manière ou d'une autre
travaillé avec les poètes et c'est ça
qui m'intéresse c'est cette relation ce
lien ceouverture d'un art vers l'autre
justement alors quand on lit tout t tous
les exégèes toutes les antologies de
poésie il y a toujours une difficulté
des auteurs à définir qu'est-ce que
c'est la
poésie moi je quand on me me dit ça
c'est une question qui n revient souvent
qu'estce que c'est que la poésieouû je
je j'aime beaucoup cette formule d'Eugen
guevi qui disait la poésie
c'est autre chose c'est autre chose il y
en a qui disent voilà c'est le c'est au
fond l'harmonie le son plus que le sens
non ça peut être la dissonance ça peut
être ça peut êt oui ça peutêre la
dissonance d'ailleurs non non mais quand
je dis oui l'harmonie peut-être mal non
mais on parle de musique de poème et
cetera mais il y a des poètes qui
travaillent sur la dissonance de de la
phrase sur la forme non c'est surtout
pas la forme c'est surtout pas la forme
moi je je je défends complètement ce
principe ce concept très scolaire il
faut que la poésie est une forme non
elle a pas de forme rainau rimau est
mort à la fin du 19e siècle ça fait
quand même plus de 120 ans il a explosé
le poème il a explosé l'Art de
l'écriture du poème et il a il a fait
comprendre que le poème pouvit être
autre chose que cet art rimé rimaillé
enfermé dans ses formes étatisées et
donc depuis depuis 120 ans on explose le
poème et on a de cesse de continuer à
l'exploser il y a encore des recherche
actuellement je pense à des gens comme
Christophe tarcos
comme Fred griot Claude Favre derrière
des gens comme j'ime sacré ou Valérie
rousau qui propos parce qu'ils ont un
travail continuel sur la langue
l'intérêt si vous voulez pour moi le
travail d'abord du poète c'est un
travail sur la langue et la langue du
poète n'est pas la langue de tout le
monde c'est une langue qu'il invente
continuellement et donc après c'est au
au à l'auditeur de donc celui qui va
l'écouter l'entendre de de de de trouver
l'entrée dans cette langue là avec des
clés quand on entre dans l'art
contemporain on n pas toutes les clés
vous é devant une œuvre de de de soulage
vous comprenez pas tout mais mais mais
on peut vous expliquer est-ce qu'il faut
aussi expliquer ce qu'il faut la poésie
non non non chacun y prend ce qu'il a
envie d'y prendre Mo ce que je dis on
peut donner des clés quand même on peut
donner des clés on en donne nous ici
parce que quand on rencontre un pote
voilà quand on rencontre un poète ici
moi je donne à entendre les voix du
poète c'est-à-dire à la fois ce qu'il a
écrit mais aussi ce qu'il a à dire sur
ce qu'il a écrit on on fait pas
l'explication de texte mais je fais
parler le poète sur son art d'écrire
c'est-à-dire pourquoi il écrit comme ça
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qu'il a attiré à
l'écriture qu'est-ce qu'il a amené à ça
l'importance aussi de la langue
française parce qu'on a une maison qui a
une mission prioritaire sur la
l'expression française je parlerai pas
de francophonie je parle bien
d'expression française dans l'écriture
qu est qu quelle différence vous faites
la je je vous renvoie un magnifique
texte avit publié à min malalouf en 2004
dans le monde des livres où il
expliquait justement que ce ce ce ce
vocable de franoponie était beaucoup
trop marqué par le colonialisme mais
aussi des invasions violentes telles
qu'elles ont été au Canada les gens qui
écrivent comme les Français voilà qui
écrivent comme il dit non voilà c'est ce
qui a donné naissance à l'écriture monde
à la littérature monde et moi je défends
cette écriture française de langue
française mais la langue française du
Camerounais n'est pas la même que la
langue française du Québécois ils ont
leurs influences leurs incidences et
l'intérêt c'est de les faire se
rencontrer et de les faire s'exprimer
dans des lieux comme ici ou ailleurs
parce qu'on n pas qu'ici qu'on accueille
des poètes on dit aussi parfois la
poésie c'est la F urance vous êtes
d'accord avec ça c'est est-ce que ça
nous donne à à comprendre le monde
peut-être plus facilement que que
d'autres formes oui oui oui moi je
défends surtout l'idée que qu disur
c'est dire voilà c'est c'est tout un
coup on comprend quoi ouais je comprends
ce que vous voulez dire mais je crois
d'abord je défends une chose c'est que
le poète il est là pour parler du monde
dans lequel on vit et il est surtout pas
un
visionnaire le poète n'est pas
visionnaire c'est il parle du monde
neroua parlait du monde céser parlait du
monde dans lequel il était s' appppuyant
sur sur l'histoire et en disant voilà on
a construit quelque chose il y a
peut-être autre chose à faire et c'est
ça qui est intéressant oui la fulgurance
c'est-à-dire que il y a dans dans dans
les poèmes il y a des éclats des éclats
de de des éclats de connaissance des
éclats de savoir des éclats qui vont
nous éveiller à quelque chose ce sont
des éveilleurs Paul etard parlait à la
suite de de de rainau il parlait des
frères voyants c'est-à-dire ceux qui
nous ouvrent les yeux sur le monde voilà
quand je dis des fulgurant c'est ça si
on il voit quelque chose que peut-être
les les autres ne voient pas il montr ou
il montrent des vois que ont une manière
de le dire que les autres n'ont pas h
euh parfois on dit aussi bah aujourd'hui
la poésie elle existe plus vraiment
c'est c'est la la chanson qu'il a qu'
l'a remplacé parce que c'était c'était
un art populaire c'est devenu un art
moins populaire qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de ça je je je je pense que la
chanson et la poésie non ne sont pas
dans le même monde quand on parle de de
chanson si vous parlez de chanson ce
qu'on appelait la chanson à texte des
des des ou des chanteurs de poète oui
d'accord on est un lien mais si on parle
de la chanson populaire elle n'a rien à
voir avec la poésie puisquelle n'utilise
que la forme poétique comme la publicité
la rime la sonance laération tout le
monde peut le faire ça tout le monde est
capable de le faire par contre ce que
dit la chanson n'est pas du tout ce que
dit le poème on est complètement sur
deux univers différents dans la chanson
on est dans une narration par exemple or
le poème est très rarement narratif très
rarement narratif d' d'ù parfois la
difficulté qu'on peut avoir à la prender
malheureusement pass le temps passe un
peu vite on va on va on va conclure
cette cette première partie d'émission
puis je vous propose on se retrouve pour
continuer à parler de poésie parce que
c'est
[Musique]
merci